[Music]
hello everyone I'm
abdelfettah and I'm google cloud
engineers based in stockholm
hello I'm dan I'm
clear engineers based in paris and it looks like
today we're going to be looking at an
internet of tools solution  things
built of end buttons on the
google cloud platform
in fact did you watch the
last four videos our colleagues talked
about google cloud haiti body pop tabs b
query and data flautre of course and
in addition I was inspired by it to
prepare the  demo that we are going to see
together today perfect let's go
then we start by seeing how to
set up a body tool to
connect manage and manage the data
of our device to internet of
things tools in English or ideo internet of
things but we  will call it and
tools later for this demo i used a
respect ripaille on which i
installed android sex since we are
looking at the cloud side of the solution
we sup  let's say you have a
device that can communicate via
http or a review
i don't want to go into the details
of how android text works
let's take a look together at how we
set up our tool device with
cloud haiti body the first
important thing and  configure to the
public and private key pair used
for connection with haiti cords since
some android devices have trouble having
secure key files on board I
chose to generate this pair when
the device is flashed if we look at
the actions of  'initialization you
see we call the people class john
ritter the public key is
saved as a pm file so that the
powerful use it to authenticate
to haiti corps for our next
step we will register our
tool device to cloud haiti  body
for this you will need google
cloud sdk is installed on your
computer your clo project id  ud
registered to eddy and the region you
want to use command line way
we used the command gicle out
haiti register create and the
information collected instead to
create another register
do you remember
the poem we created on
our device  you have to go and
get it now once
you have it saved on your computer
you can register your device
with the haiti registry created
earlier i set up and my
device with my project that it said
my region my registered at 10 mg on
device ied
so i give a look at the
google cloud console and seeing if
another device and there indeed we
see it registered with cloud 6 cores with
the id we configured
but abdel we are google yes or no with
a  single device it's not fun
quite date
hope you have a more
interesting plan exactly we will
configure hundreds of devices and  if we do
n't have space to do that no here
no but in the cloud yes we are going to
use the google cloud platform to
simulate a hundred
temperature sensors located in several places
in the world which we see data
every second towards  haiti corps these
data are dumped in real time in
a sober pop topic to which is a boonen
'pipeline' of data flow data in
order to receive the temperatures
send them to bidegorry and to the data
store finally an application barely jean will
display geolocated temperatures
on google maps by exhausting it in the data
store
let's look at the bricks of the architecture
one by one let's start with the client and
at the pti this one sends a
temperature data in three steps
it connects to the haiti body server and
authenticates itself to the  using his private key,
he creates a message m that titillates in the
format of the floor and he publishes it on a
topic dedicated to him
the client runs in a
virtual machine  from the google captain jean site,
moreover, each gysi virtual machine
used in this simulation runs
different instances of the
tool client, the launch of which is
done using a shell script executed at the
start of the same remark the
parameters received as input  by each
instance of the client and tools
the region is the name duration district with
small body its ssl certificate and its
private key as well as the city for which
it must simulate temperatures
a pipe line cloud data flow
continuously reads from a topic shortcrust pastry
temperatures  go back and every second
by the sensors here are
serious execution and the cries each message
we spoke in a table by quarry as
well as a cloud data store for
real-time display in
the app engine application
by looking at the code  source data flow
closer we notice the pi collection
or not the pop collection this message
containing the temperatures him since
pope saab
its content is  transformed into
boullereaux objects for writing in big
three and in parallel in
entity objects for writing in data store
and now launching the simulation
checking that everything is running correctly
first thing the virtual machines
in the google cloud console we
now notice the  virtual machines that
each simulate 10 temperature sensors
they were created and launched from
the app engine application
but how to verify that the
simulated sensors work and
upload data let's go back to the
google cloud console and check the list of
devices registered with our
device  aleotti corps industry here they are
continuing our investigation into big
three which is still accessible from
the google cloud console years old
note that the temperature table is
fed by a pipe line data for
a very fast sql queries will help us
to better see the latest
data  temperature rise
the cities  winners are
nicosia kathmandu and tirana
let's go back one last time to the
google club console to consult the
content stored in cloud data store
we find the cities and the
temperatures go up and save
as ntt data store
and finally by selecting nicosia on the
map in  the app engine application
we can consult in real time the
temperatures rise and by the
sensors and well thank you for the demo
please abdel and we hope
you enjoyed our presentation
this is the fifth and last episode
of  a series didier al-houti
we have tried to go to
the essentials and we invite you
to deepen the subject by going further
but how to do to get there
has indeed thanks to the quick the aps and the
resources that  you found in the
description of this video
now you would like
[Music]